Yeah.
>> Hello.
>> Yeah. Can you hear me?
>> Yeah, I can hear you now. But yeah, so
what's called when you brought up that
point about uh the Hebrews? I think it
was chapter 10 or
>> 11. Yeah.
>> Mhm.
Hebrews chapter 11. That was a good
point to see what he was doing. But
yeah, just some props because you you
know your book pretty well. But my point
that I want to bring to you is like in
Christianity, you know how once you
accept Jesus or like once you accept the
sacrifice of Christ, you're good for
life, right? According to your belief.
>> My question, Mo, isn't about what's
according to my belief. My question is
why should I consider Islam?
>> Well, I'm trying to tell you show you a
deficiency in your belief that Islam
remedies and it has like the fix for it.
>> I got you. So you're saying that Islam
has a fix for Jesus being a sacrifice
for us?
>> Well, that's not The issue isn't Jesus
being a sacrifice. The issue that I the
issue my personal issue that I have is
that like once you accept that Jesus
like Jesus sacrifice on the cross and
you're basically guaranteed heaven, then
what? There's no point for you to do
anything else on earth. Like you're
just, you know, you're just here for no
reason. You're just wasting your time.
Okay. And how does the Quran solve this?
>> So in Islam, we have a concept where we
have a day of judgment. So on the day of
>> By the way, for the for I don't agree
with that, but just going with you. How
does how does the Quran or Islam solve
this?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because look, on the day in
Islam, you know, we have the day of
judgment. On the day of judgment, you're
going to come Allah's you're going to
see it. You're going to talk to Allahh.
He's going to tell you whether you're
going to heaven or you're going to
you're going to you're going to hell.
And so you have to work all the way up
until the point of death. And at the
point of death, then everything is
sealed off. There's no point in your
life where you just, okay, I accept
Islam now. Now I'm good. Like you have
to make sure that you're you're good
until the end of your life.
>> That's not true.
>> So you don't have to be Muslim till you
die.
>> It doesn't matter if you're Muslim or
not.
>> What?
>> It it doesn't matter if you're Muslim or
not. You're already determined where
you're going to go before you do
anything or believe anything.
Well, Allah knows where you're going to
go, but you have the free will to pick
it. Like Allah knows at the end of the
day, okay, this person before you're
even born, he knows this person you're
going to go to hell or this person going
to go to heaven. But you have the free
will to pick it. So you still have
>> you you would agree that there's a
difference between like for knowledge
like what you just described knowing
something before it happens and then
being the cause of what happens, right?
>> Yeah, it is a difference.
>> Okay, I agree. What I'm saying or what
I'm arguing is that within Islam,
it doesn't matter what you do. You can
become a Muslim, not become a Muslim. It
doesn't matter what works you do. It
doesn't matter if you keep, you know,
obeying Allah, whatever, or disobeying
them. It doesn't matter because Allah
has actively
decided not because he knows what you're
going to do, but he has made certain
he's made you for heaven or he's made
you for hell according to what he's
decreed. Yeah, I heard the hadith when
you brought it up for the guest before,
but that hadith you're you're like
you're reading into it where he says
that he's the one who sent you there
because from from my perspective, Allah
just knows what you're going to do when
he since from the time he he from the
time that you were even like conceived
as an idea, he knows everything you're
going to do until like the end of time.
>> Okay?
>> So like from the time you were born,
right when he right when he right when
he struck struck you outside of from the
from Adam and he knew you were going to
come into existence, he knew what you
were going to do. That's why he knows,
okay, this one's going to hell and okay,
this one's going to heaven.
>> So, it doesn't say that he knows which
one is going to hell or heaven. It says
that he created them for such a purpose.
That's
>> well, I mean the created part, the
created part is it's a little bit kind
of like because Allahh, he also says
that uh what's called some people
there's like a group of like a certain
number of people. It doesn't say certain
number, but there's certain people who
are created for hell and there's certain
people who are created for heaven. But
those are those are like categories.
Those aren't specific people. So like
you could be one of the people you could
be one of the people who's like who's
who created for heaven. Like you could
you could fill one of those spots.
>> So it doesn't matter what I do, right?
>> No, no, no, no, no, no. That's not what
I'm saying. I'm saying that the spot is
there and you could fill that spot, but
it doesn't mean that you specifically
from the time you were born, that's your
spot. Like that's guaranteed free. It
depends on what you do with your free
will.
>> Let's So let's go with this and let's
see if it says what you're saying or if
it says something else. All right. So it
says um we already read the hadith
earlier. Let's go straight to what
Muhammad said. Okay. Aisha per
adventure. She thinks that the kid is
going to par going to paradise. Straight
shot. Muhammad says Aisha per adventure.
It may be otherwise that child who died
might go to hellfire. Why though? Why
might not that child go to paradise but
hellfire instead? Because Allah God
created
for paradise those who are fit for it
while they were yet in their father's
loins and created for hell those who are
to go to hell. He c now this is where I
mean he says it to where you cannot
confuse this at all.
>> He created them for hell
while they were yet in their father's
loins. So he created them for hell. He
created them to go to hell. Not that he
knows that they're going to go to hell
because of their life decisions. He
created them for this purpose. So it
doesn't matter what they do. They're not
going to paradise. Even if they believed
in their life, did good. Allah created
them for hell regardless. You get what
I'm saying,
>> brother. The Islamic perspective is that
Allah created people for hell. There's
people that are going to hell. Not the
specific person. There's people that are
going to hell after after they're in
their father's knowings. By that time,
Allah ben known where they're going to
go because he knows what they're going
to do. He he been already knew all that.
The people that are created is a
category. There's people that are
created and then once Allah knows what
they're going to do, then they fill that
c they fulfill the category.
>> So this is what I this is what I need
you to do for me, man. Cuz the reason
why I'm having a hard time accepting
what you're saying is due to the fact
that the verse or the hadith, it says
the opposite. It doesn't say anything
about Allah knowing where they're going
to go beforehand.
>> Look, would you you you would agree that
creating something for something is is
you being an act of cause in in that
thing, right?
>> Not no not in this not in this
circumstance. I think that when you
create something when you create
something for like if you create like
10,000 people for Hellfire, then you're
an active cause. You created you could
have you could have had everyone go to
heaven, but you said, "Okay, you know
what? I want a thousand people to go to
hell. So you're active cause for that.
But you're not an active cause for
picking. He he specifically gave humans
free will. He's not an active cause for
who chooses to go there or not.
>> So I'm just asking this very simply.
Very simply
to create something and have a purpose
for that creation. That shows that
you're the active cause, right? In that
purpose.
>> Yes. Yes. He's the active cause and
creating like a certain number of people
for
>> I got you. So he says here
that he created he created them for
hell.
So there are particular people that he
created specifically to go to hell.
Correct.
>> Uh I don't agree with that that that
wording. I agree that there's a group of
people like generically a group of
people who he created specifically for
hell. And I think that that that people
once he knows what they're going to do
then they fulfill that category. But it
doesn't it doesn't say that it says
>> seeation.
>> No, it's not it's not that's that's my
problem.
>> Yeah.
>> My problem is that I don't we don't have
to interpret. We can just read the words
on the page and what they say.
>> How does a problem when you say we don't
have to interpret like when
>> he created them for hell.
Does does it say he created them for
hell or does it say he just knows
they're going to go to hell? No, it says
he created them for hell because he
created a specific group of people for
hell. It's true.
>> Got it. So, there's specific people. The
them here. There's a there's a them.
There's specific people that he created
specifically for hell, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Not that he knows that they're going to
go to hell because of their life's
decisions, but he himself is the active
cause in their destiny destining them
for hell regardless of what they do. He
created them for hell.
>> No, not regardless of what they do.
That's why I disagree when you say
regardless of what they do. That's where
I completely disagree. And and I think
that I think that it's cuz you're taking
the text you're taking the text more
literally than I am. And I'll give you
that.
>> I'm taking the text for what it says,
brother. I don't I'm not I don't How
else can I take the text other than what
it says?
>> Yeah. Because you have to take it in
context with the religion. You know,
like
>> I am I'm taking it in context with the
religion. Your religion does not teach
that you have free will. Your religion
teaches that Allah creates people for
hell, creates people for paradise. Your
religion teaches that Allah has there's
people that do good all their life, but
then all what Allah destined for them
overcomes them and then they start doing
evil because that's what Allah destined
for them. And so then they end up going
to hell. It doesn't matter what you do.
Your Quran teaches you don't have free
will. I mean your your religion.
>> But you you agree that there's verses in
Quran that that specifically say that we
specifically say that we have free will.
>> No.
>> So when you No.
>> No, bro. Lookahan
verse two it says
let's let's do that let's do that real
quick let's do that really quick let's
look at some um Quran verses
it says it says
whoever wills let him believe and
whoever wills let him disbelieve
>> oh now that sounds like free will
however you can't will unless Allah
wills right
Yes, you can. But that comes back to
what I'm saying. Allahh, he knows what
you're going to do.
>> Because he made you do what you do. You
can No, notice this. How is it that I
can only will if Allah wills for me to
will? That's not free will. Do you
understand?
>> It is free will. It is. It's a little
bit complicated, but it is free will.
And I'll discuss, you know, discussion
about free will and predestination is a
complicated discussion. even in and all
religions. It's a complicated
discussion.
>> I I I I agree that you know you got God
God's sovereignty and man's free will.
That's a that's a that that is a deep
topic. However, what ain't deep or
confusing is when you got something
directly saying that you cannot will
unless
another wills for you. That means that
it's not my will, it's that person's
will. I
>> I don't think that's what it mean. I
think it means that you can't will
unless it confirms with God's will. So
like you can't do anything against God's
will. That's
>> So do I have the free will to do? Is it
my will or is it his will?
>> It has to be both. That's the what the
verse saying. It has to
>> How is it both if How is it both? How is
it both? If I can only will unless he
wills for me to will.
>> How is it not?
>> It is yours. It is yours. But it's it's
it's a give me a second. and I'll be
able to explain it, but it it's still
going to be, like I said, it's still
going to be a little bit complex because
of free will and predestination. It's
like it's like when you have you have
like two items, like two trains that are
going and they're they're mirroring each
other, doing the exact same thing. And
then you say that, okay, one of them is
obviously copying the other one, but
it's not that doesn't have to be the
case. They can both just simultaneously
be making the same decision. It's same
with humans and Allahh. We when we do
something and Allah predestines it, we
both do the same action. They
>> when he does what?
>> And he and he predestines it.
>> So there's no like they're both going to
be the exact same action.
>> But it doesn't have to mean that Allah
made you do it. It doesn't mean that you
made Allah do it.
>> If he predestined it, did I choose it or
did he choose it?
>> That's what I'm saying. That's what I'm
telling you. Allah chooses something for
you and you choose the same thing.
>> Yeah. And I want you to look at this.
Let's make this.
>> Yes. For whoever wills among you to take
a right course. Sounds good, right?
Sounds like free will. Whoever wills
among you to Hold on. It looks a little
blurry. Can you see it on the screen?
>> Yeah, I can see it.
>> All right, here we go. Whoever wills
among you to take a right course
and you do not will except that Allah
wills,
>> bro.
>> Yeah,
>> it's not your will.
>> No, it is your will. Do you do you
understand what I'm saying? Like do you
like uh are you following what I'm
saying?
>> How is that possible with with this?
>> You do not will except that Allah wills,
bro. What?
>> Yeah. Bas basically what the verse is
saying is that the wills have to
coincide. Your will and Allah's will
have to be the same.
>> It doesn't say that.
>> No, it doesn't say that. It says
>> brother do not will. It's impossible for
you to will.
>> It's it's you can't it's impossible for
you to will except that Allah wills. If
if Allah doesn't will, can you will?
>> No.
>> So it's
not will, bro.
>> But you see, you're not hearing me. I
told you Allah you cannot will if Allah
doesn't will if Allahhana wa ta'ala
hasn't because your free will your free
will is automatically it's like
instantaneous you only have free will at
the present moment you don't have free
will for the future or for the past
Allahh his predestination is in the
future and in the past Allah's
predestination your will cannot
contradict that your free will in the
present moment has to align with Allah's
predestination that he has pre-written
it doesn't mean that you don't have the
will to pick it but it just has to
confirm
>> there's a first.
>> I got you. So, the the problem I guess I
guess that you and I have is that I'm
sticking with the words of the Quran and
Hadith.
>> Yeah.
>> And you're going with an interpretation
that's nowhere in the scripture.
>> And there's interpret your text as well,
don't you?
>> Well, I what I don't do is when there's
something like verbatim,
I don't go outside of that. If something
is I don't go outside of that context
tells us everything yada yada yada you
yourself with your hadith in what we
read in your hadith
>> what we read in the taps here we read
verbatim explicitly
that Allah creates certain people for
hell creates certain people for paradise
>> you know I would say you're being fair
>> I would say you're being fair if you
made an effort to like uh to merge the
two verses that that that what's called
that say one is saying free will one
saying uh that you don't that's what a
Muslim would do and that's what you do
for the Bible like if you have a Bible
you have a verse that says faith without
works is dead and you have a a verse
that says works without faith is dead
you do whatever you can
>> to merge the two verses but you don't do
that for yourself
>> no
>> in verse in verse 28 it says for whoever
wills among you to take a right course
sounds like free will Right.
>> Yes.
>> I'm being fair. I'm being fair that it
I'm saying it sounds it appears like
that's straight up free will for whoever
wills among you to take a right course.
That's straight up free will, isn't it?
>> That's free will. That's that that's
exactly what I'm saying. That's the free
will. Allah tells you that to confirm
his will.
>> So you see, I'm not being uncharitable.
I can read a verse for what it says
and take it for what it says. For
whoever wills among you to take a right
course, whoever of you wills, that means
you have your desire. You can choose to
either take the right course or not.
Right?
>> Yes.
>> However, the next verse says, "And you
do not will unless Allah wills."
That eliminated
any idea that your will is your own.
It's Allah's will. You cannot will to
take a right course. You cannot choose
to take the the right decision unless
Allah wills for you to want to choose to
take IT. BROTHER, IT IT GOES beyond just
um um ch like your the choice you make
the the even desire before the choice is
not yours. You cannot will to make the
right decision. Can't want to unless
Allah wants you to want to. Can can can
God put that in your heart though? Can
God put that conviction in your heart?
Would you say that's still free will
though?
>> There's Yes. There's a there's a
difference between God convicting the
heart. But there's uh and and um and you
not being able to will something, want
something, will something. It's your
choice. Um unless he wills it for you.
That right there, that's those are two
completely different things.
>> Go ahead.
>> Hello. I I I didn't hear anything you
just said.
>> I said there is a difference between God
convicting the heart,
>> right? Working in the heart to where you
will to do God's will or you want to do
the right course
>> versus you not being able to will unless
Allah wills for you to will.
>> That those are two different things,
bro. That's like saying that's like
saying like like you know if you do
something good and you're like I would
have never been able to do this if the
Lord didn't put the conviction in my
heart to be able to do this good work
and I give all the glory back to him
because he he that's that's basically
what the verse is telling you. But
you're not seeing it that way because
you just you're coming at a at an angle
of criticism. You're not looking at it.
>> Brother, I I I'm I'm just reading it for
what it is.
>> The Bible says that.
>> Yes. The Bible says that God works on on
man's hearts and and and draws them to
him and re, you know, helps restore them
to where now they're they will to do
God's will and walk according to kingdom
work.
>> This doesn't say that. This is different
from
Yahweh. You you you you
will to do the work of the of the
gospel, but you can't will to do the
work of the gospel unless God wills for
you to to will to do the work of the
gospel. Yeah,
>> that means it's not your will.
>> What? Wait, what?
>> Say it one more time.
>> I'm going to say it one time, man. And
then I'mma I'mma go ahead and wrap it
up.
>> Yeah, cuz my section is not that good
anyways. But I had a qu my main reason
come up here. I wanted to ask you about
the salvation the salvation issue.
>> Yeah, but you said that this would solve
that Islam solves the issue of oh, you
believe in Jesus as your eternal
salvation. Therefore, you have nothing
to work towards. So, it doesn't you
don't really have an incentive to do
good works. But that that doesn't solve
the problem in Islam when you don't have
will to do your own good works or uh to
get to paradise because
your your your destiny is already
destined.
>> But you know that's not true because you
see Muslims every day striving to do
good work.
>> No, no. My my no brother Mus Muslims
striving to do good works
>> Yeah.
>> is different from what from what the
Quran actually teaches. Now I I can just
say if I'm looking at Muslims doing good
works, they only do these good works
because Allah willed for them to do
these good works. They only want to do
it because Allah wants them to want to
do it. It's not of their own free will
according to their religion.
>> Yeah. Because Allah helped them towards
that. He guided them towards that.
>> So but but in but in reality there's no
reason to even do these good works
because each Muslim your destiny is
already determined. Some of you are
created for paradise. Some of you are
created for hell. What you do doesn't
matter.
>> Yeah. I mean, that's not that that's
that's not the way any Muslim reads it.
You you can read those verses that way
if you want to. If you want to be
uncharitable and read them that way,
it's possible. I see. Like, you're not
you're not like making stuff up. But the
thing is that's just not how any Muslim
reads it. That's not charitable. And you
wouldn't read your same book that way
either.
>> Saying it's not charitable is that's
crazy.
>> Yeah. But what's called uh I'mma go
though because my connection is kind of
bad. Well, I appreciate you, man. Come
come back again, bro.